did you just complete a King Kong film I
was in uh Vietnam Hawaii Australia you
are on a major role right yeah I guess
is this the one where Kong is he
bringing up a baby or is he fighting
some other oh Kong has a baby yeah Kong
has a baby and retires he's playing
playing a lot of golf really I'm getting
my movie he opened a gy what happens
when you're in a King Kong movie like
you have to pretend you seing Kong yeah
is that annoying
you're shocked all the time yeah you
make faces uh that face wasn't big
enough make it bigger do you ever turn
to the director say I can't see him no
no you can't do that do they give you
any idea what Kong is going to look like
yeah they have a a little iPad with the
Kong cartoons on it I mean you kind of
know the girl who just won the Oscar
Brie Larsson you worked with her in this
new com movie did and and what do you
mean you loved her she is so charismatic
yeah and and so she would organize uh
she was like the only girl there on S in
Vietnam and she would organize in
Vietnam and Australia but every weekend
she would organize uh stuff to do for
people to uh would go look at Kangaroos
and uh she'd organize like a tour a a
trip to an amusement park after they
closed just uh stuff for people to do
wow because she's just over sensitive
about people getting uh uh nervous and
angry and on each other's nerves what a
nice person she's such a brilliant actor
you can't tell her acting you can't see
that she's acting when she's on screen
uh but she's just so normal and so
nice